so much of what's going on relates to
the drug crisis so you'll have a news
story about a random stabbing and a
couple days later a cop will text me and
say drugs obviously and if we can help
these people we we help clean up the
streets in general and we make our
family safer we bring back trust in the
city and then we can say all right we
will invest in building beautiful
buildings we will invest in bringing
jobs back to downtown and that's what
lets things flourish again
[Music]
today I'm speaking with Canadian
journalist broadcaster and most
importantly perhaps now potential mayor
of Toronto Anthony Fury
we're going to discuss the need for
urban renewal in Toronto the effects of
ramped up homelessness the
demoralization of the police Urban as
well as academic Decay a New Vision on
the artistic front for the city and
those pesky bike Lanes a bigger issue
than one might first think
Mr Fury thank you very much for agreeing
to talk to me today let's start with
this
you are doing perfectly well as a
journalist I presume you kind of had
your own life and that was spinning out
quite nicely why in the world did you
decide to uh you know make a move into
the political realm and run for mayor
what what impelled you to do that yeah
Dr Peterson it's great to be here thank
you so much and I get asked that
question a lot because yeah it's a big
undertaking to run for mayor of a major
city and I the main reason I'm doing it
is the issues are so acute right now in
terms of the challenges that Toronto
faces the concerns that people have and
as you know I've been a newspaper
calling this broadcaster for for well
over a decade interacting with people
all walks of life across the city on the
issues and it really just seemed like
the status quo people who have caused
these problems the city councilors the
political class you know they're not the
ones to fix that the people who broke it
are not the ones to put it back together
again and I feel like the center has
shifted in recent years such that people
are much more interested in those
positions that that I've been steadfast
on for the number of years you know
there's politicians who say I'll go to
you I'll I'll focus group I'll pull and
I'll I'll create an issue and I think
people see that they're phonies whereas
the things that I've been talking about
for the past number of years the things
that you've been talking about for the
past number of years I think people say
I want to see more of that now and more
of just regular folks the political
Center the apolitical people they want
to talk about those things now and
that's what I'm putting forward right
now that's that's what you'd be fighting
for I mean it's a as you know well
Toronto is a city worth fighting for and
and that's what I'm doing right now
so what do you think two two questions
then what do you think are the issues
that you just described
that need to be addressed by say someone
other than a member of the standard
political class what do you think those
issues are and and also
one of the reasons I decided to do this
podcast today uh despite the fact that
it's a local election in some sense I
mean Toronto is a major urban center
obviously is that
I do have the feeling that the problems
that are besetting Toronto are similar
in nature to the problems that are
besetting cities say all across North
America and probably broadly Across the
Western and even the rest of the entire
world and so what do you think
what what are the specific issues that
you have been concentrating on as a
journalist over the last few years that
you particularly think need to be
addressed in the course of this
mayoralty campaign and then in your
tenure as mayor if that if that turns
out
yeah and now that I've become a
politician I'm going to be really good
at flipping the question around and
moving to the generality even though you
asked for the specific but the
overarching generality is that they are
the issues that it takes someone to be
able to
take the criticism of the mob to move
forward on because I think so many of
the issues that have led to the Urban
Decay that a lot of our cities are
facing right now are because there have
been politicians who because 10 or 20
people show up at City Hall kicking and
screaming and call them bad names and
say mean words to them they cave on
those issues and what are those issues
they are obviously crime issues Law and
Order issues and I think the general
sense that that
politicians and cities have started
focusing on things that are Frills
things that only speak to these Niche
special interests that don't represent
the interests of the regular folks and
that the core services that we rely on
in our daily lives are not being tended
to anymore and that is the crisis of
municipal government local government
all across the Western world right now
we feel that in Toronto when it comes to
Transportation you just can't get around
Law and Order there's so much Decay on
our streets violence on the Subways
things that we have not seen in decades
and and we talk about Vancouver Seattle
La San Francisco things happening on
those streets they are coming to Toronto
and a lot of people are really concerned
and again a lot of apolitical regular
folks are concerned and again the center
is Shifting for the solutions people
want to see in regards to that
the content I've created over the past
year represents some of my best to date
as I've undertaken additional extensive
exploration in today's most challenging
topics and experienced a nice increment
in production quality courtesy of daily
wire plus we all want you to benefit
from the knowledge gained throughout
this adventurous Journey I'm pleased to
let you know that for a limited time
you're invited to access all my content
with a seven day free trial at Daily
wire plus this will provide you with
full access to my new In-Depth series on
marriage as well as guidance for
creating a Life vision and my series
exploring the book of Exodus you'll also
find there the complete library of all
my podcasts and lectures I have a
plethora of new content in development
that will be coming soon exclusively on
daily wire plus voices of reason and
resistance are few and far between these
strange days click on the link below if
you want to learn more and thank you for
watching and listening
foreign
[Music]
so let's let's uh talk as well about
what the different domains of government
are in fact responsible for so we have
responsibilities parsed out in Canada at
the municipal level and the provincial
level and the federal level and my sense
most fundamentally is the level of
government most crucial to people's
day-to-day lives is the municipal level
it's also the level that is most
difficult to get people interested in
and involved in unless they're radicals
as you pointed out and that gives them a
disproportionate sway so do you want to
outline for people what the
responsibilities of the municipality are
and how the choice of Mayor let's say is
going to affect well the realities of
their day-to-day lives yeah there's a
there's a saying that goes all politics
are local because the things that do
affect our daily lives are mostly at the
local level so garbage collection being
done for instance being able to move
from point A to point B transportation
whether that's on the roads the
sidewalks or the street cars the Subways
the public buses all of those things are
day-to-day lives policing feeling like
like the streets are clean both in a
sense that they're being garbage or
litter or injection needles lying around
on the streets or just in terms of
knowing that there's a police officer
there to deal with any disorder and you
know what I was reflecting on on this
very question what is municipal
government what is local Politics as I
was going into this race I remembered
back to My Philosophy studies and when
you look at Plato and Aristotle those
guys didn't really know much about
countries countries weren't much of a
thing that it was the city-state and all
of the original thinking about how do we
live together as a society as a
community what is Politics the original
questions around that all are actually
about cities that was the beginning
that's where it all started yeah well in
Toronto let's let's go through these
garbage Transportation crime and
policing one of the things I've observed
let's say on the garbage collection
front
is that
it's switched from being a service
provided by the city so that people can
quickly and efficiently get rid of the
things that are no longer necessary and
so the city can re remain orderly
and productive to a moral play where
Every Act of of garbage disposal let's
say is freighted with the entire weight
of saving the planet and it's become
extremely expensive and time consuming
and you know that would all perhaps also
be fine if there was some evidence for
example that recycling Plastics which
has been a big deal in Toronto has
actually done has actually worked in
that they are recycled and done more
good than harm which by all evidence it
hasn't and then on the transportation
front
um I noticed started to notice probably
10 years ago that there was something
weird going on in Toronto with regard to
automobiles because the cities seem to
be going out of its way to make driving
in Toronto as annoying as possible and
for a long time I thought that was just
stupidity and the consequence of falling
sway to the radicals in the you know I
bike therefore I'm saving the world
crowd but I started to understand I'd
like your thoughts on this I started to
understand more recently that there is a
Muni there is a Consortium of
municipalities worldwide I think they're
called C40 if I've got the acronym right
that do in fact have as a long-term goal
the radical reduction of private
transportation especially in anything
that's powered by fossil fuels which is
like everyone's car and so the war on
automobiles and the the continual
multiplication of these bike Lanes is
driven by a very anti-development agenda
and I think it's particularly
pathological in Toronto because of
course it's it's an uninhabitable City
on the climate front because it's so
bloody cold for five months of the year
and the only people that can use bike
Lanes regularly are like
fit 20 to 25 year old men
um who actually don't have anything
better to do and that's not a very good
group of what would you call
constituents to design an entire city
around so let's talk about let's talk a
little bit about bike lanes and and
garbage collection and then maybe move
to the catastrophe on the public
transportation front that's been
unfolding for 20 years for example on
Eglinton yeah and you know going back to
my saying that all politics is local
I've also found that the things that can
cause you the most controversy on the
issues you discuss are surprisingly
local the comments you just made on bike
Lanes might prove to be the most
controversial comments you've ever made
because that really gets people so irate
and I found that the the bike lane
discussion in Toronto is so polarizing
because that that small constituency of
people who who who are really fixated on
the bike Lanes oh boy they hold it
passionately but the majority of people
in Toronto say what you're saying that
we've had enough with this obsession
with putting bike Lanes in every major
road and I came out with a press
conference announcement the other week
saying no more bike Lanes on major roads
look I like biking I go out with my kids
we do it on non-arterial roads so
there's different side roads or roads
that are adjacent to Major roads where
you could put a painted bike lane but
right now in Toronto all of the bike
Lanes have these concrete block dividers
where there's such rigidity the sort of
free-flowing flexibility oh and they're
beautiful too they're they're absolutely
beautiful they've really done a great
job on the Aesthetics of the city to put
up these bloody barriers that are
totalitarian in their their hideousness
and also those plastic
tubes that obviously have a shelf life
of about six months they're as hideous
as anything could possibly be and
everyone listening who who isn't from
Toronto one of the things you need to
know about Toronto is that the city's
laid out on a grid and so it's there are
roads everywhere like there are in
Manhattan it's a grid and there's
absolutely no reason whatsoever ever to
put bike Lanes on a major thoroughfare
because there are adjacent roads that
are much underused that are actually
safer to bike on that wouldn't interfere
with traffic
particularly because in Toronto the
traffic is routed already away from
residential areas to centralize feeder
streets that feed the whole city and
many of them now have bike Lanes on them
which all that seems to do especially in
the winter when there are no bikes
whatsoever in the lanes All it seems to
do is snarl up traffic and you know
unfortunately that's a feature and not a
bug because the point is is to make
people so frustrated with their vehicles
that they decide to abandon them and
that's a pretty
that's a path that's an absolutely
pathological uh what would you say
demonstration of policy that the way you
change people's behavior is by
inconveniencing in them and irritating
them unnecessarily while interfering
with their economic productivity and
driving polarization you know it's no
and that's that could be a worse set of
policies that's absolutely the approach
here of course people are very vocal
about the idea that we want to limit
people's choice but there are videos
that have gone viral on social media
where you see when you have those
concrete block bike Lanes means you only
have two vehicle Lanes so there's
nowhere for the vehicles to go when an
ambulance passes by so lots of videos of
an ambulance trying to get through and
then how do you make space for the
ambulance if you've made those bike
Lanes so rigid so I've announced that on
some of the streets we're gonna have to
tear up those those posts you talk about
to make room for uh vehicles to divert
in in any other situation uh and some
streets we're just gonna have to get rid
of them entirely and put them on
non-arterial roads look we're all
reasonable people moderate folks I mean
there's options for all this sort of
stuff but the idea you have to to jam it
all into one thorough for there take
away the vehicular Lanes we're building
a new subway line and I announced the
other week that on those streets where
we got a major Street Queen Street
that's being shut down and then there
are other roads where obviously the
traffic's going to spill over onto and
we have an entire Lane taken up of a
bike lane we should open that up to
vehicular traffic because then you can
get Transportation moving for the five
years construction of this subway line
which to your point January February
March which we pay we pay many millions
of dollars to actually clear the bike
Lanes in the winter when when the
ridership numbers are not zero but
they're pretty darn close to zero
they're a rounding error
I like knowing exactly where my meat
comes from and with moink I know it's
coming from small Family Farms all
across the country Mike delivers
grass-fed and grass-finished beef and
lamb pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught Alaskan salmon
straight to your door Mike lets you
choose the meat delivered in every box
select an existing box or create your
own set your delivery Cadence and enjoy
delicious meat you can cancel anytime
but you won't want to if you're not sure
where to start check out their standard
box it comes with a little bit of
everything chicken ribeye burgers and
steak moink is all about supporting the
Family Farm think about it this way two
percent of Americans are farmers but 100
of Americans eat we need to show our
support for the families that keep us
well fed after receiving my first mic
box I was floored the salmon and chicken
are both fantastic and the steak might
be the best I've ever had and keep in
mind I cooked it myself with a freezer
full of moink products I can without a
doubt say it is a fantastic deal on a
ton of delicious and well-produced
products you won't be disappointed and
you can rest assured all of Mike's Meat
comes from wholesome American farmers so
keep American farming Going Strong by
signing up at mikebox.com jbp right now
in Dr Peterson's listeners can get free
bacon in your first box and let me say
it's the best bacon you'll ever taste I
re-upped my subscription because I ran
out too fast Mo ink box.com jbp that's
moinkbox.com jbp
yeah yeah well
think about this polarization issue too
because with regard to the bike lanes
because I think it is emblematic of
something that's going on on a broader
scale it's like this is something like
the equation it's something like
well carbon dioxide destroyed destroying
the planet and cars emit carbon dioxide
and so people who own cars are
destroying the planet and so if I ride a
bike then I'm saving the planet and if
you oppose me riding a bike
then you're opposing saving the planet
and anybody who opposes the saving the
planet is obviously akin to an agent of
Satan and so now you have the
polarization and the thing that
irritates me about that or one of the
many things that irritates me about that
is that
that has transformed the simple Act of
riding a bike which should be just
something you do with your family or you
do because you can in fact use it to get
from point A to B it's turned it into a
kind of Messianic moral Crusade and I
should point out to all of you who are
riding bikes and who think you're saving
the planet you are not saving the planet
by riding a bike you're just riding a
bike and so you should pull the morality
out of that argument and put it back
into the religious domain where it
belongs and we could actually have a
sensible discussion about how we could
integrate the multiple forms of
transportation that now exist including
scooters electric scooters and that sort
of thing with cars so that we could all
get around so that our ambulances could
work and so that we didn't make every
damn city street as hideous as possible
in this counterproductive way
expensively and while doing absolutely
no good and to your point as well
one of the things that we've seen
happening in the West in recent years is
that very vocal minorities are holding
disproportionate sway over public policy
and that is definitely the case in in
the biking situation particularly in
Toronto because it is a very small
minority of people who are pushing this
and so why do you think Anthony that if
you why do you think that you'll be
immune to this sort of pressure that
you've seen so many people fall prey to
like it's no joke to be mobbed and you
know what it's very very hard on people
and the radicals are extremely good at
weaponizing that mob attack so why do
you think that you'll be
able to withstand that and have you in
some ways being able to withstand that
already
yeah I mean I've been a newspaper
columnist radio show host for about a
decade and and I'm used to it you know
you say something and and you know to
your point it's something that you feel
is a totally reasonable position and
people in person come up to you on the
street and they say hey I saw what you
said I read your piece is pretty
reasonable thank you for that or people
send you a lovely email but in the
anonymity of social media people are
saying these awful Dreadful things to
you you go oh man you know I got these
50 awful things said to me go okay 50
people in a city of of well over 2
million it's actually not that big of a
deal and I think just remembering that
that people's people's rudeness people's
acting out says more about them than it
does about you I also think there's
something to be said about just not not
coveting the approval of people who are
not going to like you in the first place
and not cover not coveting
um a certain sort of social social
approval that sees you kind of
moderately liked by everyone the the
outgoing mayor of Toronto he resigned
the other month is what triggered this
election a lot of people have said to me
who were friends of that mayor they said
you know we we really liked him he was a
nice guy but he just wanted to be liked
so much that he couldn't make a single
tough decision because he didn't want 50
people to say mean things about him and
and that is ultimately what I think
stopped so many leaders from leading you
know I have uh I have a friend who was a
minister in the Mike Harris government
which which for people who aren't in
Toronto or Ontario they should know that
was a conservative government that made
some tough choices so I got a lot of
people out yelling at them in the 90s
and my friend said look if if they're
not out burning you in effigy in the
first three months not the regular folks
but sort of the niche interests if
they're not out yelling and screaming
about you what on Earth are you doing
why are you out there because it means
you're not actually making any sort of
meaningful decisions so you just got to
be willing to take the Heat and I'm
willing for the mob to come for me
that's a good inversion of the fear is
that so your claim fundamentally is that
if you're not annoying irritable
ideologues you're not doing your job
yeah that's I think that I think there's
some real there's really something to be
said for that uh
um so I'm going to go in two directions
now the first is
um what makes you think that you're
qualified for this job like what does it
take to be what does it take to be
qualified for the job of Mayor what
makes you think you're qualified in an
absolute sense but then also what makes
you think that you're qualified in
comparison to your opponents who we
should also discuss
and to lay out the what would you say
the the entire situation on the
mayoralty race front so
why are you qualified to be mayor in an
absolute sense to begin with OR why do
you think you are being in the media for
the past 10 15 years in this city doing
the columns doing the radio work when it
comes to Municipal issues it puts you in
touch with people from all walks of life
all spectrums of society all across the
city you hear about their concerns and
then as you're writing about studying
interviewing meeting with people about
these issues you're meeting with the top
decision makers and I I don't think
politics should be about kidding
yourself that you're the smartest guy in
the room I think it's about
acknowledging that you have the ability
to get the smartest Galler guy into the
room to say okay we're dealing with this
or that I gotta have the humility and
good sense to say get me that guy as a
principal tenant of leadership and as
I've been devising these policies I mean
I'm not pulling them out of thin air I'm
saying get this guy on the phone get
this person on the phone and we're going
to figure this out you know but bring
the best here and throughout the past
decade I mean I've been I've been
getting in touch with the bad fast as I
navigate these issues and it's it's
never it's never been me myself it's
been me navigating it with these
people's guidance and and you bring them
to city hall because I think part of the
problem is that that the status quo
politicians only bring on those special
interest Niche activists and just
Elevate their voices I want to elevate
the voices that are actually able to get
things done I'm you know so many people
in the business community and they all
say why aren't we bringing business best
practices to City Hall why and whatever
you want to call it there's all these uh
zero-based budgeting lean Six Sigma
there's all these different terms they
have about bringing managerial practices
to the public sector why is none of this
being done and I say to them that's an
excellent point I will bring that I will
Elevate those voices I'll bring you guys
to the table
right so you feel that you've been in a
position to aggregate the concerns of
torontonians serving as a journalist but
also that you've made contact with
people who have genuine competence in a
variety of areas and you would be
willing to consult with them to find the
best Solutions going forward I mean I've
met with leaders all over the world and
tried to generate what would you say a
theory of competent leadership and I've
seen I think you actually hit the nail
on the head hit two Nails on the head
with your description because the first
thing I've seen that characterizes
people who are genuine leaders this sort
of independent of whether they're
normally on the left or the right is
that they actually go out and listen to
people
so one of the things that the the word
lobbyist you know the word lobbyist is
derived from this old practice in
England where you could meet your Member
of Parliament in the lobby which was the
central building in the house of
Parliament and you could call on them at
any time so that you could discuss your
concerns with them so being a lobbyist
actually well the lobby was where the
politicians actually met the people and
the great leaders that I've seen really
listen to their to their constituents so
uh Preston Manning for example when he
built the Reform Party which was quite
an act of leadership he told me at one
point that the part of the campaign to
build that
party that he enjoyed the most was the Q
and A's after the speeches he gave in
arenas and so forth across Alberta
because by listening you know in 150
different locations to what people were
concerned about he could find out what
their problems actually were and then
start to generate policies that were
focused on people's actual problems then
the next point you brought up was that
you know if you're
this is another
characteristic of great leaders that
I've seen in a variety of Realms is that
they're perfectly willing to surround
themselves with people who are more
informed and smarter than them on any
number of issues you know they they
don't they don't have the kind of ego
that demands that they're the smartest
person in the room all the time and so
they can call on people who are true
experts without what would you say
sacrificing the responsibility of the
decision-making to those experts because
that's also another danger as we saw
with kovid and so okay so you think
you've you've managed to to talk to a
lot of people and you know what the real
concerns are in Toronto and that and
that you've been in a position that
enabled you to do that over like a
decade and also that you do have the
ability to identify people that are
competent and the willingness to listen
to them and that do you have any qualms
on that front like if you were looking
at your weaknesses
procedurally with regard to your team
what what do you think they might be
what what do you need to have bolstered
as you go forward
well you just want to bring everybody to
the table more voices and you want to
get out there and you want you want to
meet as many people as possible identify
as many people as possible whether it's
whether it's the uh the you know the
small business people who I've been
meeting with over the years or whether
it's the the influential people I mean
it's it's finding that sort of uh
perfect combination of bringing everyone
to the table when it comes to lobbyists
the big corporations they are able to
pay to have someone come and book a time
to meet you at City Hall and and talk
about their grievances but I found the
smaller businesses the medium businesses
the ones still run by the families I
mean they're just not able to do that
they can't afford that obviously to hire
a lobbyist and uh they they have to
fight a lot more aggressively to just
get the air time for politicians so you
want to go to them I've said I'm going
to convene a mayor's Roundtable of small
businesses and restaurateurs which is an
industry that's just been totally messed
with and decimated and of course
restaurants are one of the things that
people say people don't say I'm going to
Paris or Rome or Toronto because I want
to try the McDonald's at this
intersection they go I want to go to
that that unique restaurant I've heard
so much about yeah we've totally gutted
that industry uh during covid so so
giving them a voice too including those
voices you know I I was in Romania here
the other day and I talked to one of the
ministers in the government there and
they've put together a system they call
ion ion and it uses a chat GPT like
artificial intelligence system to
aggregate public concerns and to bring
them to the attention of their political
leadership so you know you said one of
the weaknesses perhaps in in your
operation is that
you you see the necessity of making
contact with groups of people who don't
have a lobbyist paid lobbyist voice and
that's a constant challenge back to the
issue of competence and Leadership you
know you want a leader you want someone
who's intelligent on the general
cognitive ability front you want someone
who's conscientious and dedicated and
then you want someone who has a very
wide social network because that's one
of the multipliers of competence right
if you know people who know how to get
things done well AE you don't have to
know you just have to call on them and
then you have to get the hell out of
your their way if you have any sense so
you're you're telling everyone who's
listening that you know one of the
challenges you face is trying to figure
out how to expand that social network so
that you're aggregating the concerns of
people who don't necessarily know how to
make their voice heard I think the
restaurant example is a really good one
because as you said that that's that's
crucial to the
to the kind of culture in a city that
might bring in tourists for example and
and attract well and and that's a major
that what would you say that's a major
an increasingly major economic force and
something that Toronto would like to
Pride itself in being a cultural center
and so
all right so so let's talk let's talk a
little bit about your vision for the
city if if Toronto was what it could be
five years down the road or ten years
down the road and you had a hand in
determining that
how would the city change direction and
what might you see happening
down the road
um on the city development side I mean
we have the whole waterfront that's
quite the catastrophic Mass although
that seems to be improving uh and
there's lots of things about Toronto
that work well what would you like to
see improved and what would the city
look like if it was really thriving yeah
and you got to start from the premise
that you just love this city you love
everyone in it it's a city worth
fighting for and you're going to throw
your passions in it a hundred percent to
it and the the frustrations right now
the concerns oh we're slipping towards
being like Seattle San Francisco awful
videos of things happening in Vancouver
where you have a downtown that is is
increasingly in Decay it's being
hollowed out and the people who have
taken over the streets or people who are
who are just not doing well and they
need they need help and some of them
need incarceration depending on what
they're getting up to and you know we
really want to develop those places that
are primed for beautification you're
right talking about the Waterfront areas
where other cities have totally
beautified them and at the same time you
want to deal with those Decay aspects
one thing that has been front and center
to what I've been campaigning on is we
have a lot of random attacks going on
the streets of Toronto on public transit
and that's why everybody is saying
Public Safety is such a concern they're
nervous people say and it doesn't matter
whether I'm meeting with a small
shopkeeper or the executive they say my
13 year old used to take the subway
alone I'm not letting it happen anymore
the Subways are dirty literally there's
people sleeping in them camping on them
they smell of pests people are just so
unhappy that it never used to be that
way I had a Carefree childhood teenage
years
growing up in Toronto and I was
gallivanting all around town and it was
just great so much of what's going on
relates to the drug crisis so you'll
have a news story about a random
stabbing and a couple days later a cop
will text me and say drugs obviously and
we have this growing number of drug
injection sites that is really enabling
this a compassionate Society doesn't
keep people on drugs it helps gets them
off of it and I have found alarming
stories about attempts by the city to
create new injection sites called
another name I went to a public hearing
where there's a senior center in North
York and they have some green space in
front to do their Tai Chi and so on and
that green space they're putting what
they call Modular housing for
chronically homeless men you go okay
what does that mean and then they add
and there will be harm reduction on site
oh okay you've actually explained what
this is you're going to create a drug
injection site on the front lawn of a
seniors complex their only green space
drug dealers they're pretty smart people
they go to where the customers are so
obviously they're going to go to this
site it's going to be total little Decay
and that's why I have said as mayor of
Toronto no more new drug injection sites
we're going to take the allocated
resources we're going to flip them into
treatment centers to get these folks off
of drugs the goal should be to put these
injection sites out of business to phase
them out and we're helping these people
reclaim their lives because I've been
speaking to parents who are so worried
about their kids on the street who are
just in violence they're being arrested
they're hurting themselves they're
hurting other people they want them off
of it and if we can help these people we
we help clean up the streets in general
and we make our families safer we bring
back trust in the city and then we can
say all right we will invest in building
beautiful buildings we will invest in
bringing jobs back to downtown and
that's what lets things flourish again
yeah well it doesn't look like turning
over Municipal spaces to drug adult
homeless people and their dealers
constitutes a move forward forever for
anyone I mean the countries in Europe
like Portugal that have liberalized
their drug laws with some degree of
success have actually paired them this
is something that people in Vancouver in
particular the politicians in Vancouver
haven't seemed to clue into one bit is
that Portugal for example didn't just
decriminalize drug use it also set up
very stringent rules surrounding
acceptable public behavior on the drug
use front and so the policy is something
like well it isn't obvious that
criminalization of drugs has proved to
be a particularly successful social
policy but that doesn't mean that you
get to you know scream in a meth-induced
rage and run Toothless and naked down
the street right those aren't the same
necessary policy and what I have seen in
Ontario in particular this this ominous
tendency to presume that
homeless people so to speak have a right
to Municipal territory
by right of their I don't know what
catastrophic disarray and that it's
incumbent on everyone to turn over our
green spaces to people who are homeless
which is a Preposterous notion because
it means that
your misery now entitles you to real
estate and to public real estate and a
highly valuable public real estate at
the expense of other people and there's
nothing in that policy that's the least
bit sensible there's certainly nothing
in it that's compassionate as well
because from a psychological perspective
that looks a lot like enabling to me if
you make it easy for people to continue
to destroy themselves you're not doing
them a favor and you're certainly not
some kind of hero you're just putting
forward bad policy because you're
ignorant because you want to feel good
about yourself and if you're doing that
at the expense of Municipal property
that's valuable the green spaces for
example then and making them unsafe
there isn't anything good in that for
anyone absolutely and one of the
challenges we have in Toronto
affordability crisis people can't afford
homes anymore so more and more young
families are living in downtown with
their children and they take condo
spaces and they're not that many parks I
mean Toronto has a shorthand known as a
city within a park because there is so
much green space and trees which is
great but actual parks where you can go
out and have a great picnic and a great
time downtown there's not that many of
them and past couple years they have
been taken over by encampments which is
why I'm saying as mayor of Toronto know
the public space must be available to
people and to families to enjoy and are
we compassionate about these people
having their troubles you bet we are but
they can't take over the parks and the
tent encampments must go down so the
public space can be reclaimed by the
people it's just getting warm again in
Toronto we've got to be able to enjoy a
summer without these tensions happening
again where kids can go down a slide
without the parents having to go oh are
there needles on this side I've had that
very experience we now live in the East
End of Toronto we live downtown in
condoland and I have had to say sorry
son you cannot go down this slide
because well there's the needle right
there and I'm not picking it up because
you know I don't have the right material
to uh to deal with this stuff so we got
to move on I mean that's just awful yeah
so so
um okay let's talk about the the let's
get down to the Brass tax on that front
I mean
when you
say something like well we need to
we need to take the parks back from the
encampments
how the hell are you gonna do that I
mean I'm I'm imagining that I think well
if you want the woke mob to attack you
in a very successful way it seems to me
that a media campaign showing the brutal
hand of Anthony Fury oppressing the
homeless in parks in Canada that's a
that's a hell of a fine story and I'm
sure there's no shortage of narcissistic
journalists that would go to town all
nights like let's in in the we can take
the example of a single Park how would
you envision actually going about that
um what once this Camp the camps are
established like what do you do with the
homeless people that are there and how
do you actually take action without it
being an ethical catastrophe well the
police go in at the right time and they
get rid of the tents and they take the
people out and they move them to another
location that's how it's done it's the
only way it can be done and I will make
sure we do it one of the reasons it
hasn't been done before two big reasons
one the politicians are afraid of
encouraging that policy because they
don't want the headline saying oh look
what this guy did I know the silent
majority is on my side though that we
just can't have this compassion yes but
you can't take over the parks number two
one unfortunate thing that's happened
with the anti-police movement in recent
years is the police feel demoralized so
so many officers tell me what is the
point of doing my job if I do my job
follow protocols and I'm not talking
about the ones that don't follow
protocols and do awful things they have
to to obviously follow all the
consequences of being bad cops but the
good cops who are just trying to do
their job and then they're thrown under
the bus by the politicians and their own
Chiefs we have a chief of police also
running for mayor here who demoralized
his Force he threw the force under the
bus if you allow that to happen if you
demoralize your police force obviously
they're going to stop doing the job and
they don't feel like there's any reason
to do it because they're just going to
be punished for doing it so one you say
go in and do this clear the parks and
number two
when the headlines start coming for me
I'm not going to go oh I can't handle
this so I'm going to blame the cops I'm
going to throw them under the bus for
something that I initially encourage
them to do no we're going to bring back
Law and Order and I'm going to have the
backs of the officers I'm going to
support the police so do you do
how are the police reacting to your
campaign do you have any sense of
whether the rank and file officers are
in support of the sorts of things that
you've been putting forward they are and
I'm having a lot of meetings with
officers both officially and
unofficially uh to hear what's really
going on and to say I support you guys
and and to get the sense of what's going
on on the ground to speak to the Beat
cop although I to clarify that phrase B
cop there one of the things that they
identify as a problem is there aren't
beat cops anymore you walk around the
streets of Toronto you're not going to
see any police officer just walking the
streets and that was a normal thing for
decades that was how policing used to
work right now people walking downtown
Toronto go the next person who turns
that corner could be a person in a
drug-induced psychosis who's going to
attack me I'm nervous about that I want
to get us to a situation where people go
the next person turns that corner could
be a cop so both the people feel a sense
of assurance and anyone who's thinking
of causing trouble knows well okay I
better careful because the next guy
around the corner could be a cop who
stops me from making that trouble
so why were the police taken off the The
Walking beat do you know do you know how
that came about because we increasingly
put our investments our tax dollars and
our political Capital into these shiny
new baubles these distractions these
Fringe projects and we let the core
Services be ignored so it's a funding
problem I mean we have defunded the
police in Toronto without a doubt we
have fewer police officers in Toronto
now than we did 10 years ago despite the
fact the population has grown where did
all this crime come from where's all
this disorder well well obviously cause
effect that's what's going on right now
and we got to turn it around we have to
invest again in the basics whether it's
public transit which I'm going to do or
in policing and and we've we've just got
to do it we have to reprioritize
okay so let's talk about public
transportation we could talk about
well while the war on automobiles has
been raging in Toronto there's also been
a tremendous amount of noise about
improving the transportation system the
public transportation system and most of
that's been noise and I think that
Eglinton is a very good example of that
so the LRT System Light Rail transit
system there have been plans to to make
that functional along the eagleten Route
and that whole
major business thoroughfare has been a
quagmire and Nightmare for what 20 years
something like that and with no real
progress of any sort evident on the
transportation front and yet we hear
stories constantly coming from say China
which I'm not holding up as a shiny
example by the way
um of the ability to lay like literally
hundreds of miles of Subway down within
you know a two or three year span so
like
the the the subway system in Toronto for
a city of its size and wealth is pretty
damn shoddy it's it's insufficient
I've lived in Toronto for 20 years the
development plans on the subway side
have been appalling to say the least
very little has got done it's
unbelievably expensive it's caused
endless disruption now apparently the
plan is to shut down Queen Street so
what is it going to turn into another
Eglinton that doesn't seem like a very
good plan given how essential Queen is
to the entire culture of Toronto so like
what's going on on the public
transportation front and why put more
money into a system like that if it's if
it's already been demonstrated for 20
years that the city is for some reason
incapable of managing it properly and
that's why I came out and said that I
will be suing metrolinks the agency
that's creating all of these lines for a
billion dollars for breach of contract
and damages because this Eglinton line
was supposed to be finished a while ago
two years ago they took the median
politicians on a tour and said look it's
over 90 complete and it actually worked
they took the train from end to end
what's the problem they're not closers
they can't get it done they can't do the
granular they've just found out there's
no credible timeline to complete it
there are over 250 deficiencies and city
council and the good people of Toronto
are expected to just shrug and go oh
well another delay and I've said no it's
not acceptable my team and I read the
contracts you're in violation of so many
of these terms we're suing you for
breach of contract because we got a
light of fire under their rears we can't
keep taking this anymore yes we're all
sort of polite Canadians but at a
certain point you have to go we're being
abused here we have to fight back we
have to stand up for ourselves and that
lawsuit should hopefully set the tone
that this new line the Ontario line it's
called along Queen Street a downtown
relief line we're grateful this is being
built it's long overdue so I'm going to
be a willing partner with the other
levels of government and getting it
built but you guys better not mess
around and you better stick to schedule
because I'm showing we're serious now
about holding people to account this
idea that contractors in the public
sector can just totally screw up on
things in a way that the private sector
would never tolerate we just can't be
doing that anymore to your point about
China I can bring it closer to home I
was touring this beautiful Hindu temple
this mandir in in the west part of the
city and they are telling me the
construction on it how it did not take
very long they brought people in from
India who are experts it's such a
beautiful building so so finally rod and
so many details to it and they built it
in such a short period of time I was
just I was just gobsmacked I said we got
to bring you guys in to build the
Subways you know because you're closers
and they're not like come on
well what seems to happen on the policy
front constantly is that
virtue signaling narcissistic
politicians announce huge spending
projects and then they make the case
that the spending is the accomplishment
and then they spend the money but they
don't do any of the work necessary to
actually supervise the spending Because
the actual benefit of the spending isn't
the spending because any idiot can spend
money the the benefit is the results now
if you've done even a home Contracting
project you know perfectly well
that you have to keep an eye on the
project all the time there has to be
someone there making damn sure that
everything is I mean you have to have
competent people doing it but even then
if you let a home construction project
go unsupervised for any amount of time
first of all it'll grind to a halt and
second the costs will multiply
extensively so particles the contractors
have other jobs and so you know they're
putting out the noisiest fire to mix
metaphors terribly they're always
putting out the there's fire that's
producing the most smoke and noise and
so the same thing it scales the same
thing happens on Major League
construction projects and one of the
questions that's burning for me is like
well
who the hell abdicated their
responsibility on the Eglinton front and
I guess the other thing I'm curious
about is you know if I was a Eglinton
business owner I would have been
inclined 10 years ago to go light a fire
at City Hall I mean what's happened in
Eglinton has destroyed the lives of many
people over decades long period these
are hard-working people who put a
tremendous amount of money into their
businesses and they've just been screwed
over in 15 different ways another
example of the pathology of Canadian
politeness I mean they they shouldn't
have been putting up with that at all
it's just it's beyond belief that
traffic snarl and the mess that's been
created there and so
um what
what makes you think that you'll be able
to number one go after this company
successfully without them just folding
and disappearing or claiming bankruptcy
and disappearing and number two to put
in place people who actually have the
expertise to supervise these projects so
they'll actually be completed on time
particularly Jermaine given that you
know the plan is to shut down Queen
which you know strikes me given the
Eglinton example as a pretty terrifying
thing to to undertake
yeah well we've got to change the way we
approach these issues your point about
the the home rental projects is so
important I remember a house that I had
we brought in some roofers and there was
a major problem with it and I said look
guys like you've got to be held to
account on this and they wanted more
money even though it was their own
ineptitude and I remember at one point
one of the guys shrugging saying well
look Roofing is hard I said I know it's
hard that's why I didn't do it myself
that's why I hired someone who claims
that they have 30 years experience and
they're the experts in all of this so
it's all about holding the contractors
to account and right now the provincial
government is trying to say to this city
oh it's the contractor's problem okay
guys manage the contractors because
that's your sole job and one of the
interesting things in government is we
have so many people paid really good
six-figure salaries to not just do the
job but to Outsource it and to manage
the Outsourcing and it's like guys
you're 500k salary you're not even doing
the job your job is to manage the
contractors we should be expecting that
from you so part of this lawsuit that
I'm that I want to get going here as
soon as I get get into the mayor's
office is both and I should say that
billion dollars I want to redistribute
those funds in part to those businesses
that you identify as being quite wrongly
aggrieved and and of course losing some
of their life savings over all this this
is to to reframe how we approach this
and to reset who is the boss because
right now increasingly I I think in in
public sector contracts people who get
the contracts almost feel like they are
the boss so I want to reframe the way we
approach it and that we can manage this
uh very rigorously we can demand
Excellence because part of the problem
is we're just not demanding excellence
and accountability
obviously in the interests of crooked
contractors to drag out a high-paying
job as long as possible especially if
you can also uh combine that with not
doing the work which is a good way of
saving costs so the the impetus for
making these projects inefficient is
absolutely clear especially like I said
if you're dealing with corrupt
contractors and so
um have you talked I presume that you've
talked to Legal advisors about the uh
advisability and practicality of such a
lawsuit what have they what have they
told you and and I mean this isn't as
far as I can tell this isn't common
practice with regard to the
relationships between uh municipal or
provincial government and contractors
right doesn't generally degenerate into
a billion dollar lawsuit like what makes
you think that you can go forward with
this on legal grounds uh well because
you read through the contracts and it's
glaringly obvious that they are in
breach of contract on a number of fronts
so you proceed from that and actually I
mean you're right but when it comes to
dealing with the subway system actually
the contractors are currently suing the
provincial government over their own
grievances so it's like these guys again
that the contractors think they run the
show they've actually come in against
the lawsuits and the City of Toronto is
once again the passive player and the
residents are are just expected to take
it I want to get the city of Toronto in
the game I don't like endless litigation
but the contractors are the ones who
almost have the greatest inertia they
got the biggest balls at the table right
now and again we gotta say no we're
getting in the game too we're we're the
only ones not triggering legal action
right now so again that just puts us on
the defensive and we don't have a voice
at the table wait okay well we've talked
a fair bit about you know some of the
uh remediating some of the idiocies that
currently plagued Toronto let's say on
the bike lane front and the park front
and the public transportation front
might be fun for a bit to talk about
what the city could look like I mean one
of the things that's really struck me I
was in Montreal not so long ago and
Montreal has done a lovely job of
revitalizing their their old city and
the and the and the Waterfront so it's
it's extremely accessible to people it's
very very beautiful it's a lot of fun
which and that's something Montreal is
really good at I mean that damn city man
it's produced a Civic life that's just
top rate you know if you're speaking of
world-class cities there's probably one
in Toronto or one in Canada and that
would be Montreal given all the things
that it has to offer and Toronto claims
world-class City status constantly which
is one of the reasons you know it's
actually not true because if you are a
world-class City you don't have to yell
about it constantly but we have this
amazing waterfront that's because the
whole city is spread out along this this
gigantic lake with its beautiful beaches
but so much of that is still marred by
construction rubbish and like detergents
of the last 150 years of pointless and
and counterproductive planning and like
the city could be very Waterfront
centered and there has been some moves
on that front right downtown with some
real
wow progress made I would say over the
last 20 years I mean then there's night
time in Toronto too I think what was
done with the CN tower for example
lighting it up that's kind of fun and
playful and many cities across the world
have instituted these festivals of
lights that make their cities really
glow and dance at night and like Toronto
could be a real hopping place it has the
possibility for that very well developed
Waterfront and like a very exciting
downtown and and a a cultural Hub if
that was handled intelligently what do
you see on the positive front
for Toronto under your under your
guidance as mayor
as mayor I'll say yes to big bold
exciting and fun ideas because Toronto
has become a city of no and we always
look for reasons to knock things down
what we call tall poppy syndrome there's
something that's going to be very
inspirational very powerful well let's
come up with reasons to actually
criticize it instead I've been speaking
to a lot of real estate developers who
have some very ambitious ideas and when
development is coupled with with
beautification with boldness it can be a
really powerful thing to rebuild the
city because you don't want the
bureaucrats and you don't want the the
politicians behold to special interests
you want the people who are who are the
the great innovators and what so many of
these developers say and also other
forward-looking sectors like the tech
sector for instance what so many people
in these sectors say development Tech
sector that things are so slow moving
rigid and negative when it comes to
planning when it comes to approvals when
it comes to red tape are you speaking to
one developer who said he's been waiting
six months for a meeting about whether
or not this wall is kept or not as a
Heritage designation wall and I said
well what's the problem here what's the
hold on he said well the guy comes by
from the city and then he says okay I
got to go back for this other paper and
then the meeting is pushed for six weeks
later I'm like why can't you be a closer
you get the guy in the room you're
looking at this darn wall yay or nay and
just close the deal right then and there
what's the problem so you want to
expedite all these things it's almost
like we're deliberately uh dragging our
feet on all of this if you want a
beautiful city uh tomorrow and we should
have one yesterday but if you want it
tomorrow you've got to start saying yes
to things and approval processes are so
slow
Well here here's an example so and I
haven't I've been traveling a lot in
recent years and so I haven't paid as
much attention to this particular issue
as I might so my knowledge might be out
of date but I noted that there was a
there was a protracted attempt in
Toronto to diversify the food carts away
from just hot dogs which is kind of what
they are now hot dogs and sausages and
there was a notion that given Toronto's
thriving ethnic communities that we
could set up a system of food carts and
that could offer an incredible plethora
of different dishes and this is hap this
happens in places like Manhattan for
example and those Street
um those Street restaurants let's say
are good entry point for people who want
to start a new business and they do add
a lot to local life because they can
move to parks and so forth but the last
time I checked none of that had happened
all the carts were still serving hot dog
sausages and french fries essentially
and that much touted diversification of
food cart hasn't occurred at all had no
current at all it seemed to me a classic
you know very local and detailed example
of that culture of no that permeates
Toronto thinking I saw a lot of that at
the University of Toronto for example
there was always a thousand reasons why
something interesting and exciting
couldn't be done you know covered up
with a patina of we celebrate Excellence
it's like yeah I don't see much evidence
of that plenty evidence to the contrary
what's happened do you know what's
happened on the food truck front and do
you think that's emblematic of the kind
of problems that you've been describing
it is and the issue has regressed so the
other year we introduced something
called Cafe Tio where because of covid
and indoor spaces were in lockdown so
they said okay we want to have more
outdoor spaces so we're going to
expedite letting you have patios that
are just uh on the sidewalks or even
sometimes in the in the parking spaces
there we'll just let you turn it into a
patio so it would be like a Parisian
experience and great awesome so we did
it and then this year they've decided
you know what let's start charging we
let them do it for free let's charge
them three thousand dollars for each one
of these patios you're like why what's
going on here because it's a cash grab
because they realize we can do this we
you know they started it they've already
put the outlay for it now now we've got
them let's get the 3 000 out and we'll
bring in 20 million dollars on all this
dinging them all hold on a second this
is a great it's a beautification measure
it gets gets the place jump in it's
brought in all this economic activity so
of course how can we take something from
them how can we how can we screw them
over on the sly a little bit and so many
businesses are outraged I came out uh in
front of the cameras the other day I
said no Cafe to fees I'm axing them I'm
getting rid of them we shouldn't be in a
situation where government wants to
micromanage everything stifle everything
and key to government how can I get
money out of this how is this a revenue
opportunity and that's really concerning
and that plays into uh how they can't
get the food truck game going and the
general approach to any good thing that
comes along
so when you're out talking to people now
tell tell me some of the stories that
you've heard from people that that are
talking to you on a day-to-day basis
that that have struck you most deeply
and that you regard as say pointing in
an emblematic way to the problems that
the city faces I mean you've been
talking to people all over the place and
what's that what's that being like and
what have you learned well like I said
everybody brings up the public safety
issue it doesn't matter where they are
on the spectrum of society one story I
will never forget a father uh knew my
positions on the drug injection sites
his daughter has been all through the
system in in tragic ways he he told me
completely sort of sober faced uh
emotionless his family story of the past
couple years he spoke for about 20
minutes straight to tell his daughter's
story
um I was in tears at the end of it
um and I was just hearing this story I
always thought the father reliving it
it's still ongoing it is an absolute
tragedy what's going on in our streets
in terms of enabling the drug culture
um obviously there's so much violence
hospitalization the girl had been been
pushed into into sex trafficking and and
just horrendous details and this is
happening people's daily lives and yet
because we have a small number of
activists who stand up and use buzzwords
around harm reduction uh we're just
supposed to not say boo about this we're
supposed to accept it all I'm not gonna
a very deeply human emotional
conversation with a father in pain an
ongoing pain for that family and I'm not
supposed to do anything about it because
20 people are going to hold up a placard
with a rude word about me not cutting it
that the safety issues and the Urban
Decay are so real it is just Dreadful
these videos coming out of Vancouver
Seattle everyone says they're seeing
that stuff on Instagram on Twitter they
don't want to see Toronto go one step
further in that direction and my
commitment to the people of Toronto I've
said is mayor of Toronto I will stand
strong on that stuff we're going to
clean up the streets or else we're just
gonna Decay further so would you regard
that like if you had to make another
Factor I've noted that characterizes
leaders rather than Pretenders is that
they actually have a list of priorities
because the the pseudo leaders
have a hundred problems and they're
going to solve all of them and wherever
they turn someone has a problem and
they're instantly offered the assurance
that that's going to be a top priority
and the thing about top priorities is
that there's actually one top priority
you know and you can't do everything you
have to make a hierarchy of necessity
um it's one of the reasons I like Bjorn
lomberg's work on the on the
environmentalist front for example is
he's rank ordered Solutions according to
cost benefit for example and so it
sounds like what that one of the primary
priorities that you would have as leader
is is that it's Public Safety broadly
that includes cleaning up the parks that
includes making the subway safe is that
your number one priority how does that
fit in with
the idea of like beautification of
Toronto and development of of Economic
Opportunity where do you see your
priorities how would that be laid out in
your first say year of government
Public Safety is a hundred percent key
it's my main priority phasing out the
drug injection sites getting beat cops
back on the streets so people feel like
this city is something they can make
beautiful again they want to make
beautiful again they can build buildings
here people are going to buy those
buildings pay property tax which gives
us the funds to keep investing in things
businesses say I do want to reinvest in
downtown because my employees feel like
there's a place for them to live and a
safe place for them to live where they
no longer want an exodus from both
downtown and it's spilling out to other
parts of Toronto as well if you don't
have Public Safety if people don't want
to be in the city then it's a
non-starter and we've got to bring Law
and Order back we got to bring back
those assurances do you have any
concerns out
well I mean one of the concerns and I
suppose it's a reasonable concern is
that if you if you
are pushing a Law and Order platform
that you tilt the city towards excess
policing towards excess authoritarian
heavy-handed authoritarianism and
obviously that can be a problem because
there can be too much policing and as
there was during the covid era let's say
the so-called pandemic of authoritarian
virtue
um How do you
do what dangers do you see on the
policing front and do you have some
sense of how
you might ameliorate the concerns of
people who are afraid of a more Law and
Order approach
yeah and a couple years ago when people
were taken to the streets across North
America to protest the police more
broadly I never once said in my
commentary don't do those protests don't
go out there and and I've never said to
anyone don't protest don't make your
voice heard because part of that
experience was reminding police that
their job is to serve and protect the
people they're hired by the people and
they respond to the people's concerns so
there's a pressure valve moment where
people want to get their thoughts out on
the police and hold them to account by
all means do it the problem is what we
did a few years ago is we threw the baby
out with the bathwater the pendulum just
went Bonkers in totally the wrong
direction defunded the police
demoralized the police and detassed the
police that's the phrase officers use
when they're speaking to me took away
the things they do so right now I'm not
particularly afraid of going in the
wrong direction I just want the pendulum
to get back to normalcy right now
so when the police
that they've been detassed my suspicions
that has something to do also with the
removal of localized autonomy right I
mean policemen have to be able to make
their own decisions at the micro level
because
well someone in a managerial position
isn't on the ground and watching the
situation and individual policemen get
thrown under the bus a lot for doing
that and obviously that's going to be
demoralizing and when you when you talk
to policemen about their concerns about
doing their job what sort of things are
they telling you that are interfering
what are they afraid of
Toronto has a broken windows problem
where all the minor infractions are
totally allowed there is zero policing
of minor infractions and that sends the
message that well why not do a major
infraction if no one cares about the
little things are they going to care
about the big things so the detask means
that there was a time when you'd call
9-1-1 or call the local division
directly and you'd say we have some
graffiti here or we have a guy causing a
disorder problem my house has been
broken into my car was stolen you're
increasingly redirected to this service
3-1-1 where an operator who's not at all
connected with the police says okay sir
I'll take a note and maybe one day
someone will get back to you I'll give a
very real example I saw in my community
Facebook page that there were injection
needles under these risers under these
bleachers at a park right near where my
where my kids play and someone said
watch out these are here but we called
the service because they say don't touch
the drug needles because the great thing
about having all these injection sites
is all these these experts who deal with
this stuff so don't you touch them we're
going to bring the experts he called
this service the needles were not
collected I went and took a look I I
called the service again to say are
these needles getting collected they
just never were and they say oh yeah
someone will be there to pick them up
and they're just not issues where who's
even dealing with these issues anymore
detask just means they're not responding
to things car thefts are massive in
Toronto right now part of the problem
and we haven't really spoken about the
media yet but because
mainstream media is being hollowed out
there's tons of layoffs people are not
actually reporting on what's going on
and they don't really have a sense of
just how much crime has gotten out of
control unless they're on top of it so
Community Facebook groups will post the
news releases that are on uh the Police
website that talk about these sexual
assaults these stabbings these robberies
and they get to people via their
Community hubs but they're not in the
news so if you're not in those Community
safety Facebook pages you're or if
you're not talking to someone who's had
this stuff happen to them you're
oblivious to what's actually going on
and it is brutal right now the volume of
things you know I was in the capital
city of Albania a while back and unlike
most eastern European cities it is
graffiti free
and you might think well that's who
cares and I would say well if you
traveled through Eastern Europe you'd
care and this is also true of Rome by
the way because there is uh an
assortment of magnificent architecture
that's absolutely marred and it's not
bloody well marred by street art it's
marked by miserable little Psychopathic
Thugs who are doing nothing but tagging
and the cities look Dreadful as a
consequence and they actually fixed that
in Albania they had about 50 people to
begin with tasked with going around and
painting out the graffiti but they
started working they started finding the
graffiti artists so-called and they
identified the small number of them that
were actually talented and figured out
how to use their talents in a more
productive way and so they've managed to
reduce their graffiti removal team to
one person and the whole city is clear
of this Scourge and it really is a
Scourge and I think it is a broken wind
Scourge is that if tagging is allowed to
go unaddressed first of all it adds to
the general ugliness of the city and
that's demoralizing it shows that the
thugs can uh what would you say manifest
their Psychopathic narcissism without
any danger of being stopped and that
does encourage broader scale
um what would you say social misbehavior
and crime and so
well
I've been trying to think through
what processes might be necessary to
bring
a vision of
you know when artistically thriving
but well-ordered Society into being and
this idea of co-opting some of the
people who are involved in these in
these uh
and these low-level criminal activities
seem to be an interesting one I mean you
talked about the broken window problem
you talked about
the needle problem for example and the
the fact of homelessness in the park
what other elements of Urban Decay do
you think are sending the wrong message
to people in Toronto one big issue that
so many different groups talk to me
about and I've met with Hindu parent
groups Asian parent groups uh meeting
with an Islamic Association so many
concerns about an issue you've talked a
lot about education and the school
system now the mayor of Toronto does not
run the school system it's a provincial
issue but you have a relationship with
the head of the school board and the
trustees an ongoing relationship and
I've told these parents I will be your
Advocate I will elevate your voices
because they are very concerned about
the lack of academic Excellence instead
there's a lot of advocacy a lot of
activism going on in the school system
and that schools have become zero
consequence environments where the
broken windows theory is almost being
taught in the worst possible ways in the
system that that as kids there's zero
consequences to things you know my wife
and I are always telling kids hurry up
you're going to be late for school what
are you doing this is unacceptable you
can't show up to hockey late you can't
show up to class late and yet there was
a time when I was a kid when if you did
that well you'd there'd be a problem it
would be acknowledged that you you let
the team down you've let the class down
maybe you have to go to the office it's
marked on the page and now there's no
consequences so we're kind of saying
come on guys and then when it actually
happens and there the the couple times
they are late or the kid who's late
every day they go mom dad why are you
nagging us about this this is clearly
not a problem we can it doesn't matter
you don't have to do all this I don't
have to remember to do my homework if I
don't do my homework what are the
consequences nobody cares if I don't do
my homework and I'm not I'm not blaming
the teachers or at least I'm not blaming
all of them for this because a lot of
teachers tell me that this is a problem
as well the system just doesn't allow
this to happen because again going back
to the policing there we we reached a
crossover point where principals
teachers superintendents who did bring
consequences to kids where they were
needed they were thrown under the bus by
the politicians by the senior
bureaucrats so we have this cascading
problem at the education level as well
so why not when you graduate from high
school or you know you're in grade 10
and and school lets out why not go do
tagging on on people's private property
I mean what's that there's no signal
that that's uh something one shouldn't
be doing
yeah so that's part of the that's part
of a reflection of this broader social
malaise and also the increasing
hyperdominance of the radical types who
you know use this narcissistic
compassion to twist things around and so
so you got involved in Municipal
politics and
um what is what has that done to your
journalistic career at the moment like
what are you putting on the line to to
run this mayorality campaign I mean if
you win obviously you're going to be
mayor but if you lose if what happens if
you lose what what do you go what what
do you have waiting for you do you go
back to your Journal do your career in
journalism how does that work out I'd
like to think I have a lot waiting for
me because this has just been such an
amazing experience and I say if you want
to fall in love with the city of Toronto
all over again and and remember what you
like about it you run from there because
you just meet so many amazing people and
and people open up their doors they open
up their hearts to you so I I think
everything opens up when you just go
around and you make those meaningful
human connections I'll say particularly
coming out of a period where we we
weren't making human connections for a
good two years and as you know Toronto
was one of the most locked down
jurisdictions in the world to sort of
reopen things and just sit down and have
meaningful human connections this has
been such a great privilege for me and I
think regular folks really want the sort
of stuff that you've been talking about
for years that I've been talking about
uh for years so I'm in it to win it and
you know every day we're making
connections with new people and more
individuals joining the team because
because they want to go in this new
Direction and The the people uh the The
Fringe Niche activist agenda is
increasingly I think
losing momentum people don't realize
that they're undeniably on the down that
all the indicators show that these these
folks do not have the influence and
power uh they did and it's time to put
the regular folks back in charge again
and we can do it okay so okay okay so
let's let's talk about that you you made
two points then I'm going to ask you
about the alternative skin to to to
being mayor let's say because I'm
interested in the price you pay for this
but you made the case
I've been talking to people in my
audience is that you know if they're
concerned about what's going on in the
political front especially with regards
to the more extreme activist types that
they should really think hard about
involving themselves in the political
process because obviously something's
wrong
and obviously if people who are Centrist
and competent don't involve themselves
then people who are extreme and
incompetent will take over and that's
and so you know part of the rise of the
woke nightmare is also the abdication of
the competent and so now you said you
know you got involved in this political
campaign and it's actually been really
good for you it's been heartening It's
Made You More optimistic and you said
that it would be good for people to join
the team so maybe one of the things you
could help people understand practically
is
if people wanted to be of service to
your Enterprise say right now what
concrete steps could they take to do
that and then also why should they do
that what what would be useful and
productive on their front for you know
taking the time and energy to involve
themselves politically so first of all
how would they do it and then what would
you know what would what they might what
might they learn and how might they
develop for doing it yeah thanks so much
for the opportunity so you can go to my
website fury.ca f-u-r-e-y dot CA we're
looking for people to obviously vote to
spread the word to get involved as a
volunteer to commit whatever talents
they may have it's all about activating
different networks meeting with people
getting the word out and obviously
campaigns also cost money so to make a
contribution which you can make at
fury.ca and there is a rebate program
where you actually get about 75 percent
of your money back after the after the
election they just write you a check
back it's how the system works right now
so I say would you give me 75 dollars
and people say oh yes I would I say oh
well then could you give me 300 because
they're going to give you 225 back so
that's uh you're only on the hook for
the 75 and why do it well because we
have a great opportunity here I will say
practically speaking it's a very divided
field and there's about eight people
with with serious campaigns who are
running for mayor right now most of them
are in the left of the spectrum and
they're all going to be fighting over
each other for those left-wing votes I
feel like I'm pretty much the only
person who's out there in the same
aspect of the spectrum and those of us
who are like-minded have this
opportunity because while I want to win
a mandate widely across the city and all
voices matter and I want to get as many
votes as possible this can actually be
one with only about 18 percent of the
vote is kind of the number that a lot of
the strategists say so I will be in it
to exceed that 18 but to definitely get
that 18 and the rest of the field is
crowded whereas there's a whole terrain
out there uh that that I can totally go
out and capture and it's about
activating the network so anybody who
has a community group a church group a
group of friends a Business Association
say hey that I like what Anthony's
saying I want to bring him on a zoom
call or want to get him to an event or
let's do that because it's all about
spreading the word and and more people
are joining by the day and the word is
spreading I just feel so great about it
I feel like that there's only upside uh
to me for this and and for everybody in
Toronto who wants positive change
okay so I'm gonna outline that in a very
detailed way so
you can contribute financially
and you can vote those would be kind of
the entry level what would you say
contributions right I should classify so
I don't run a foul of election laws here
only people in Ontario uh can contribute
not just torontonians but everybody in
Ontario but people people outside of
Ontario aren't eligible to contribute
right okay okay that's a good
clarification so you can vote you can
support it financially then you said if
you're the member of a community if
you're a member of a community group if
you have some local uh Charisma and
clout then you can contact your campaign
to make that network available to you
and to your team so that would be useful
for people who are
organizers at the business level for
example or or in other community ways
um if young people want to volunteer to
help
what would what would you have them do
like they're I I know people go
door-to-door in campaigns for example
that's a very good way to cut your
political teeth you meet a lot of people
that way you have to develop your social
skills very very rapidly because you'll
meet every sort of person you can
possibly imagine by going door to door
knocking and you'll find friends and
foes quite rapidly and so you know
that's good experience for people who
who haven't had that kind of experience
if a young person wanted to volunteer
you said they could go to your website
that's fury.ca what what would you ask
them to contribute and what
opportunities might lay themselves out
for them yeah and they can email me
personally Anthony
fury.ca the opportunities that we'd lay
out is you're right the door knocking is
just such a big part of it whether it's
just Distributing Flyers to people's
houses to get the message out or or
knocking on doors making those
meaningful connections or we go to
places like a very large attended events
or local farmers markets and it is that
human connection and that's what it's
all about me saying this is my vision
and also what's your vision for the city
what are your thoughts and you made an
excellent point uh earlier on in our
conversation where if you hear the same
thing from 10 20 100 people you go well
these folks are on to something and
there's a wisdom on the street and part
of the problem uh with the the people in
politics right now is they they deny
Street wisdom so it's it's people
joining me to really make those positive
connections with people all across the
city and to meet with people who you
maybe otherwise wouldn't have met with a
neighborhood you don't always go to or
or or or someone who you just normally
wouldn't see you go wow and the great
thing and one of the things that the
social justice Warriors get so wrong is
they want to accentuate our differences
but when you just start getting on
meeting people you realize our
similarities are so much more powerful
and profound than our differences and
you come together with someone who you
might think I don't have a lot in common
with oh no you do have a lot in common
with them so please everybody join the
team and we're going to go out and do
that we're going to knock on doors
distribute Flyers we're going to
organize Zoom call calls join me at
events as as I go out and connect with
people and it's just it's so cool to be
in that car with a team and go we're
going out to this event and that event
and it's a pack schedule I'm working and
as things ramp up the elections on June
26th I'm just going to be working like
18 hour days but it it it's amazing it's
a beautiful experience and I'd encourage
everybody uh to join me yeah well you
know one of the things that young people
who are listening might consider is that
it's very useful as you attempt to make
your way through life to improve your
social skills to improve your ability to
talk to a wide variety of people and to
listen to them and to expand your social
network and you can do that in with
Incredible rapidity by getting involved
in the political campaign
you door knock you're going to meet a
lot of people than you met before in
your life you're going to get a lot
sharper on your feet and then if you're
the least bit useful and reliable then
people who will at some point in
principle have some access to
Opportunities they're going to know who
you are and if you proved yourself
useful those doors are going to open
like mad and so there's nothing in it
but upside and so for those of you who
are listening and who are concerned on
the political front or who have some
political interests or who are maybe
just cynical it's like well get out
there and get involved a little bit and
and see you'll see for yourself quite
quickly that the institutions that
govern our society are actually quite
functional if we actually use them and
so and it's a good opportunity so I'd
encourage people who are watching to do
this no absolutely I mean my Rolodex has
only grown in terms of the great
connections I've made the people I've
met and these really like I said genuine
positive connections and then people
join the team and they're meeting all
the different people these people
obviously people in the business
community and in the Arts world and in
this sector in that sector and you're
interested in this you go hey I you know
I I met this guy on this campaign a
couple years ago now I'm doing this new
product I got to get back in touch with
that guy again I mean the people who get
involved in political campaigns yes
there's political junkies but it's also
people from every sector every Walk of
Life and and the creative opportunities
that come from we're all coming together
for this shared interest to make our
city better but then bam it opens the
door in the world for for anybody on the
team to do so much more with the
connections they've made you're totally
right it it really is it's a movement is
what it is
yeah well and it's it's such a good
opportunity for young people because
political campaigns are generally
extremely desperate for help of all
sorts and so you actually want to go
somewhere where people are extremely
desperate for help of All Sorts because
then you're even your rather limited
intelligence talents because you're
young and you don't know what you're
doing are welcome and and then you have
this opportunity to take on
responsibility that otherwise wouldn't
be granted to you and to learn in
extremely rapidly and so if you're
looking to Foster your career which
shouldn't be your primary goal on the
political front but you know things can
work in concert a political campaign is
an excellent way of learning about the
city and and and developing your your
skills and your Social Network so and
you know I I want to drive home the fact
too that if responsible people don't
take up their political responsibilities
then irresponsible people take up the
political responsibilities and then you
tilt things toward a kind of
non-productive
narcissistic tyranny and that's not a
good idea and that's happening
everywhere very rapidly and I think one
of the ways to remediate that is to get
involved at the local level where things
actually happen and so it's part of the
reason you know why your campaign
interested me maybe we could close a
little bit
um
what kind of vision do you think the
people who are also running for mayor
putting forward that's different from
yours and and how would you contrast
that specifically like who who's the
front runner is Olivia Chow the front
runner who's the front runner in this
race at the moment on the on the more
Progressive side yeah Olivia ciao for
those who don't know is sort of like the
the Elder States woman of the far left
movement all across Canada and she was a
federal politician for a while uh her
husband who who passed away was the
leader of the left-wing party in Canada
she's now seeking the mayorality again
she was rejected 10 years ago she wants
to I guess get her revenge on the good
people of Toronto and those ideas are
about tearing down the gardener the
major highway just tear it down at a
bike lane to pretty much every single
Street bringing in more taxes I
guarantee you that's going to happen
they do not believe that City Hall has a
spending problem which I believe I can
talk about this stuff in great detail
the financial matters but uh what so
many of the other guys want to do is
just look for opportunities to just
steal more taxes from people
they've all the counselors running for
mayor voted to proceed with this
Municipal sales tax so a whole new level
of tax oh don't worry it'll just be one
or two percent in the first year yeah
right and then four and then five and so
forth they're going to get addicted to
the revenues from it if we have an
affordability crisis right now which we
do with the rising price of food is this
a good thing for folks particularly
low-income folks absolutely not
shopkeepers disincentivizing them
they're coming up with all these other
crazy new tax entirely new taxes that
they're gonna try and impose upon people
that is not the right way forward it's
not the responsible way I have said flat
out no to these new taxes and instead
what we got to do is be responsible with
the books and if we grow our city the
more units of housing You're Building
well there's property taxes that come
with that so you're building your
revenues that way you're doing a
positive growth a positive way of
growing the coffers by by inviting more
people into town to share in this this
great city building project we're doing
all right so we'll sum up so
your primary concern is to
re-establish Trust
and and reasonable trust in in public
safety to ensure that the city doesn't
degenerate into a crime-ridden nightmare
the way so many cities have degenerated
and continue to do so and you believe
that if you do that well that's going to
restore people's faith in the downtown
for example and encourage development
encourage habitation one of the great
things about Toronto compared to many
North American cities is that the core
downtown core is very
um residential and so it doesn't have
that ghetto-like aspect of of just Stark
business with no life that characterizes
so many
cities in North America that is a great
advantage of Toronto you you see uh a
positive Vision on the beautification
front more development of parks uh a
more vibrant artistic and culturally
alive Toronto you're not particularly
fond of
um increased taxation you are looking at
intelligence solutions to Transportation
which don't involve for example
multiplication of bike lanes that do
nothing but interfere with the flow of
traffic you want to do something to
remediate the corruption on the
transportation front especially that's
plagued areas devastated areas like the
Eglinton Corridor
um and you've encouraged young people to
involve themselves in your young not
just young people but also young people
to involve themselves in your campaign
you said that was fury.ca
f-u-r-e-y Dot c-a and your your email
address again for people who want to
contact you directly is Anthony fury.ca
right okay well I think that's probably
not a bad place to end this is there
anything else that you'd like to say to
the people of Toronto but people more
broadly as well who are watching this
because they're interested in the issue
of Municipal politics is there anything
else you'd like to say before we we
close off yeah thank you for the
opportunity all politics is local we've
got to take back our cities from this
Decay it's happening in cities all
across the Western World all throughout
North America Toronto is a city worth
fighting for and on a number of fronts
the municipal issues but advocating for
parents for parents rights the number of
parents who come up and say why are they
sending grade threes home with surveys
asking are you non-binary or not people
of all walks of life all political
backgrounds left-wing parents gay and
lesbian parents are saying this stuff is
Bonkers it's gone too far and like I
said at the outset the center is
Shifting and it's shifting in the
direction of the sort of things that you
and I have been talking about for years
so that's the the opportunity and that's
the play here and that's why I'm doing
this and why I'm so passionate to become
the next mayor of Toronto all right well
we'll close with that for everyone
watching listening you know that many of
you know that I spend an extra half an
hour with the people that I talk to on
the daily wear plus platform we'll talk
about more autobiographical issues there
I'm interested in how Anthony's
interests in journalism and in public
policy more generally unfolded across
time so we'll address that and whatever
other issues we feel are germane along
the way for all of you watching and
listening on the YouTube platform thank
you very much for your time and
attention to the Daily wire plus people
for facilitating this conversation
setting up the technical end and the
film Crews who are involved in Toronto
and I'm in Thessaloniki Greece doing
this video right now thank you to the
film crew here for making this well
flawlessly on for putting this together
flawlessly on the technical front much
appreciated Anthony we'll uh
continue to communicate I'll be back in
Toronto second week of June and I'll be
there for quite a while
um and so well we'll get a chance to
talk some more maybe there's some event
we could do together that might be fun
we can talk a little bit about some of
the more Visionary ideas that we've been
discussing behind the scenes that would
also be entertaining and so thank you
very much for well for running for mayor
first that's no trivial thing you know
you have to you have to put a fairly big
detour in your life to manage that and
then also for agreeing to talk to me and
my audience today oh thank you so much
Dr Peterson it's been a pleasure and an
honor
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com